[Music]
in there 4000 year long history toilets
have been through a lot but I bet
they've never seen something like this
what if everyone on the planet
coordinated to perform the biggest flush
mob in history pushing all the waste
water in the world down the drain
all at once could the world's sewer
systems handle this kind of flush
pocalypse or with the big flush clogged
up residential plumbing and flood your
home with well waste this is what if and
here's what would happen if everyone on
earth flushed at the same time don't be
shy
we humans spend about 13 months of our
life going to the toilet flushing may
seem boring and routine but only for
two-thirds of the world's population
about 2.4 billion people lack access to
proper sanitation but that leaves us
with over 5 billion flush mop
participants what's the worst that could
happen the effect of the big flush would
be anywhere from not much happened to
epic pipe explosions and yes the waste
could back up into your home the moment
you flush your toilet your waste goes
down the pipe and flows into a sewer
system first it goes through a system of
pipes under the street then it runs into
progressively bigger pipes all the way
to your local wastewater treatment plant
the treatment plant pipes are designed
to hold a whole lot of wastewater but
are they big enough for everyone to
flush at the same time that's not
something we can know for sure until we
try it could get ugly the first thing to
get overwhelmed by the vast amount of
waste would be the lift stations these
are stations that serve to push your
waste uphill towards its final
destination the treatment plant but you
can only push so much poop up the pipe
eventually the pipe gets overwhelmed and
can't handle any more wastewater at that
point it would back up to where it all
started your bathroom your toilet would
begin to overflow with substances that
were supposed to be delivered to the
treatment plant and it wouldn't stop
there the overflow would fill up every
wastewater line in your home including
your shower your sink even your washing
machine not all of our pipes will be
able to handle this excess many will
begin exploding underground and flooding
the streets with waste yeah that's quite
a mess but it's not necessarily going to
happen this way you see we might flush
all our toilets simultaneously but that
doesn't mean that the wastes will make
it to the sewer system at the exact same
time your waste might have to travel a
further distance than the waste of your
friend who's flushing two blocks away
this means that the pipes might still be
able to handle the flush pocalypse
depending on how good the sewer system
is where you live in that case the worst
thing to come out of this flush mob
would simply be a big ol waste of water
and while you're flushing freely without
guilt some people live each day without
that luxury making do outdoors they
might pollute their own water sources
and get sick from waterborne diseases if
only we had a cure-all for every illness
would we become immortal well that's a
question for another what-if
[Music]
you
[Music]